et
notre invité politique c'est jean pierre
raffarin bonjour mais je suis content
avec nous ce matin d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ancien premier ministre bien
évidemment jean pierre raffarin
président des fondations prospective et
innovation est leader pour la paix et
auteur de ce livre choisir un chef c'est
aux éditions michel lafon les secrets du
leadership à travers l'histoire et on va
en parler tout au long de cette
interview puisque sa touche finalement à
beaucoup de sujets d'actualité et on est
ensemble pendant un peu plus de vingt
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale et un journaliste que vous
connaissez bien jean pierre raffarin 6e
bise de la nouvelle république qui est à
nouveau avec nous re bonjour baptiste
bonjour monsieur prémunissent toujours
bonjour oriane bonjour chers tourangeau
j'ai quitté le plateau double clin
d'oeil de l'ancien sénateur de la vienne
et ancien président de la région poitou
charentes voilà c'est une promotion
bravo et tous nos voeux pour la réussite
dans cette nouvelle fonction
aimetti sera donc avec moi pour cette
interview jean pierre raffarin on
commence par l'actualité et c'est
nicolas sarkozy hier convoqués à la
barre dans le procès de l' affaire des
sondages de l'elysée alors qu'il est
protégé par son immunité présidentielle
c'est une première cette convocation il
a jugé sa convocation totalement
disproportionnée il a dénoncé une
décision parfaitement anti parfaitement
anticonstitutionnel et il a donc refusé
de répondre aux questions il a gardé le
silence au nom de respect de la
constitution at-il dit l'élu raison je
pense qu'il a raison aussi le président
de la république
ancien mais qui a assumé cette
responsabilité ne fait pas respecter
notre pacte commun qui est la
constitution qui le fera respecter je
pense que la justice avec nicolas
sarkozy est malhabile elle doit défendre
d'état de droit mais elle doit pas
donner le sentiment d'une sorte de
harcèlement qui ne sert pas la grande
cause du droit et de la justice en
france est ce qui équivaut à un
harcèlement de la gestion chez job je
pense que vis-à-vis de nicolas sarkozy
quand on le menace de le faire à mener
on sait très bien que si on convoque
nicola sirkis devant la justice nicolas
sarkozy ne partira pas à l'étranger il
sera là donc c'est pas la peine d'avoir
ce type de provocation qui cherche un
peu l'humiliation mais je crois pas que
ça fait avancer le droit on va parler de
la coop 26 qui se tient actuellement à
glasgow c'est baptiste qui va vous poser
la question à sion c'est vrai que cette
coque 26 a débuté sans dashing ighrem le
premier pollueur de la planète et xi
jingping n'a pas quitté la chine depuis
le début de la pandémie cela ne
participe-t-il pas de votre point de vue
l isolement diplomatique de son pays à
ça je pense en effet que c'est très
préoccupant la chine se replie s'enferme
quelque peu disons que nous sommes dans
une compétition aujourd'hui puisqu'on
parle de leadership
c'est vraiment cette tension entre les
états unis et la chine pour avoir le
leadership mondial on appelle ça le
piège de thucydide c'est le numéro un
qui ne veut pas voir l'émergence du
numéro deux et le numéro 2 qui se
verrait bien la place du numéro un alors
on a eu la guerre qu douanières et
maintenant on est dans la guerre des
diplomaties quand l'un quelque part
l'hôte n'y est pas et donc je crois que
c'est très dangereux parce que la paix
ça passe par de la diplomatie ça passe
par quoi le dialogue est qu'aujourd'hui
on est dans une situation où on se parle
guère entre l'occident et l'asie et
c'est quelque chose de dangereux et je
pense qu'il faut être très attentif à
pouvoir faire en sorte que le
multilatéralisme et notamment les coop
et tout ce qui est lié au travail de
l'onu puisse reprendre avec une volonté
d'apaisement sinon nous courons des
risques de vraiment de désordre mondial
she's in ping c'est une grave erreur
c'est ce qu'a d'ailleurs joe biden le
président américain vous partager ça moi
je pense que oui nous pouvons nous notre
point de vue considéré que c'est une
erreur le seul problème c'est que c'est
une bataille avec les états unis que
quand les états unis il nous faut un
coup comme l'australie c'est aussi une
arrière donc ce qu'on voit bien c'est
qu'on est pris aujourd'hui dos dans
cette
nouvelle organisation des relations
internationales qui est marqué par cette
tension etats unis chine et que
finalement nous la france et nous
l'europe nous sommes très fragiles face
à ces deux géants on va y revenir mais
question de baptiste ce genre sur la
coque c'est vrai que si on revient aux
enjeux climatiques la chine avait été en
pointe au moment de la coupe de 21 pour
permettre la conclusion des accords de
paris cette fois la part est en retrait
incapable de se passer de ses centrales
à charbon peut-on réussir la transition
climatique sans la chine bien sûr que
non peut-on réussir la paix sans lâcher
non peut-on réussir sans les etats-unis
non il nous faut que tout le monde soit
autour de la table est donc aujourd'hui
quand on regarde un peu partout dans le
monde on voit que il y à des risques
graves de tensions notamment entre les
régimes autoritaires et les démocraties
entre le nord et le sud les convois les
questions religieuses et le terrorisme
donc on est dans un monde de désordre
cependant le cheikh a bâti je pense
qu'il ya quelque chose de de positif
dans cette coop 26 c'est ce consensus
qui apparaît sur la planète comment j'ai
commencé la politique la planète n'était
pas un objet politique on ne parlait pas
de la de la planète ont parlé du
tiers-monde mais là on voit
qu'aujourd'hui la planète est devenue un
enjeu et c'est un enjeu notamment pour
les sociétés civiles et notamment pour
les jeunes et je crois que c'est très
important parce que le multilatéralisme
qu'il faut défendre c'est-à-dire
l'organisation internationale de la
gouvernance ce multilatéralisme là ils
étaient fondées sur ce qu'on appelait le
consensus de washington
c'est à dire le consensus de la
performance économique quel principe sur
lequel la banque mondiale a été fondée
le fmi était fondée on demande au pays
d'avoir de bonnes gestions pour
apparaître comme vertueux mais ça ça
devait pas un consensus mondial des
sociétés civiles aujourd'hui la planète
isation que la nouvelle version de la
mondialisation c'est quelque chose qui
est finalement est soutenue par les
jeunes par les sociétés civiles et je
crois qu'il n'y a pas de paix sans
consensus alors dans le grand désordre
aujourd'hui il ya quand même cette aile
une lumière d'espoir qui est que la
planète devient un objet consensuel
politique pour peu que l'on puisse se
rassembler dans ce qu'il faut
naturellement c'est que tout le monde
revienne autour de la table mais vous
savez on a connu ça monsieur trump avait
quitté
les accords de paris il avait quitté
l'om s puis dernier revenu j'espère que
tout le monde va revenir mais la paix ce
qui est mon combat principal emmonak
études première la paix elle passe par
le fait que tout le monde soit autour de
la table vous êtes optimiste pour un
accord sur cette coque 26 je pense qu je
pense qu'on avance le le g20 s'est pas
mal passé je pense que on progresse et
je vous dis ce qui est très très bien
c'est que les jeunes de san francisco de
bengalore de shanghai ou de
chasseneuil-du-poitou sont tous en
faveur de la protection de la planète au
fond on parlait beaucoup de en france de
l'humanisation de la mondialisation mais
finalement défendre la planète s'est
humanisé la mondialisation on parle et
vous en parlait en de cette guerre de
leadership entre les etats-unis et la
chine en mots sur ce qui se passe du
côté taiwanais une délégation
parlementaire européen qui est
actuellement à ottawa à taïwan une
délégation sénatoriale était à quelques
jours ce qui a mis en colère la chine
qui considère taïwan comme une de ses
provinces est ce que les parlementaires
ont raison d'y aller et est ce que vous
êtes inquiète des menaces récurrentes de
la chine envers taïwan je pense que
taïwan est le sujet de tension qui peut
mal tourner et donc c'est sûr que il
peut y avoir une initiative chinoise
mais il ya aussi des initiatives
américaines puisque la flotte américaine
est très présente là-bas et donc il peut
y avoir des frictions qui viennent de
part et d'autre donc je pense que nous
devons être très attentifs
moi j'ai toujours été favorable à la
diplomatie parlementaire et donc je
crois que c'est c'est bien y compris
quelques fois dans les dix principes
parlementaire n'est pas tout à fait en
accord avec la diplomatie des états je
pense que c'est bien qu'il y ait des
avancées et je pense que en france on ne
connaît pas très bien j'irai tout le
contenu politique de cette affaire
témoigne que des parlementaires
travaillent cette question pour essayer
de défendre des idées de paix parce qu'à
un moment voudrais bien parler de paix
donc je crois que c'est c'est pas
inutile que la démocratie parlementaire
je sais que le sénat avec la présence de
christian cambon fait du très bon
travail sur le plan diplomatique et ces
complémentaires du travail de l'état
vous nous parliez tout à l'heure de
cette crise des souverains nouvelle
étape il erre dans cette crise colère d
noël macro après la divulgation d'un sms
qu'il a envoyée au premier ministre
australien qui vise à laisser penser
qu'il était au courant d'une menace sur
le contrat des sous marins avant
l'annoncé officielle de sa rupture est
ce que la france est en train de se
faire éjecter de ses hôtes de cette zone
pacifique sud par ces années et est ce
que les états unis et l'australie sont
encore nos amis le visait à jenny se
sont très mal comporté dans cette
affaire et l'australie également et le
président la république a eu raison de
faire part de son courroux sur cette
affaire je pense que les choses se sont
passées comme si nous étions pas
justement des alliés et donc nous sommes
des alliés est donc là il ya évidemment
quelque chose qui c'est qui s'est brisée
et ceux qui nous appelle à une réflexion
sur quelle est notre place dans ce monde
bipolaire entre la chine et les
etats-unis peut-on compter sur les états
unis pour nous défendre dans le futur
comme ils l'ont fait dans le passé c'est
pas sûr et des coûts comme ceux là sont
des coûts extrêmement gras et donc la
seule perspective
c'était une grande thèse de mon livre
sur le le logiciel leadership européen
et donc comment donner à l'europe un
leadership et là on a une circonstance
puisque on va avoir des élections en
france on avait des élections en
allemagne le rapport franco allemand va
être stabilisé dix ans pour les cinq ans
qui viennent à partir du printemps
prochain j'espère que c'est l'occasion
d'avoir un leadership franco allemand de
l'europe s'il n'y a pas de leadership
franco allemand de l'europe il n'y a pas
de leadership européen et le risque
c'est que l'europe sorte de l'histoire
que les deux puissances nous écrase il
faut donc là vraiment je pense faire en
sorte qu'au printemps français et
allemand et la même vision des
etats-unis et la même vision de la chine
pour l'indépendance de l'europe un mot
sur un dernier mot sur ce qui se passe
dans cette zone puisque c'est là que se
trouve la nouvelle calédonie un
référendum nouvelle calédonie dans un
mois si les calédoniens choisissent leur
indépendance est ce qu'il ya un risque
de pénétration chinoise pour vous bon
bah je pense que dans cette zone là le
la force dominante est évidemment la
force chinoise dont il est clair que si
la france devait reculer la chine avant
serait donc c'est très important pour
nous de garder ses positions là parce
que la france a une vocation d'avoir une
présence dans le pacifique et du coup
est ce qu emmanuel macron doit
s'impliquer dans ce référendum est le
gouvernement est resté plutôt silencieux
sur les premiers référendum il n'a pas
donné de position est là il faut qu
emmanuel majoritairement je pense que
c'est une c'est un sujet sur lequel la
mobilisation nationale doit être forte
en effet on va parler de l'union
européenne baptiste mais c'est vrai que
jean pierre et du leadership européen
sur la scène internationale sur la scène
politique intérieure européenne les
choses ne sont pas simples non plus
l'union européenne at elle raison comme
elle le fait en ce moment de réaffirmer
ses valeurs fondatrices au risque de
heurter les opinions publiques dans
certains pays de l'est et puis question
annexe quel regard portez vous sur les
régimes polonais hongrois en particulier
m'écoutais je
pense d'abord que l'europe sa devise
c'est la diversité à l'union dans la
diversité
donc il faut pas non plus s'affoler dès
qu'on a des divergences à l'intérieur de
l'europe l'europe est une une démocratie
démocratie 1 donc il est clair que ça
nous demande une certaine sensibilité
nous sommes une originalité de
l'histoire mais il faut dire on a une
force considérable c'est que cette
originalité de l'histoire elle il sortit
de la monstruosité et des guerres et
donc on a réussi à dépasser l'horreur en
se rassemblant et quand on dit ça je
vous assure en asie à des japonais ou à
des chinois qui n'ont pas vraiment
solder leur histoire notre europe elle
fait quand même force d'addex ce message
là donc nous devons avoir confiance dans
l'europe accepté notre diversité mais je
crois que il est clair que dans les
institutions européennes
aujourd'hui ne se dégage pas un
leadership suffisamment puissant pour
pouvoir parler avec force et aux états
unis et à la chine c'est ça le problème
de l'europe mais est-ce qu'on est dans
des simples divergences auraient ce
qu'on est dans un risque
je pense que on a été dans un risque de
déconstruction avec le break site mais
je pense que aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
avec les
pays de l'est aujourd'hui certains
d'entre eux je pense que il y a des
divergences qu'il faut pouvoir accepter
négocier discuter mais la diversité
européenne fait que les nations sont ce
qu'elles sont les ont leur histoire et
elles ont leur sensibilité ce qui compte
c'est un pilotage à un moment ou à un
autre d'une énergie qui fascine la
diversité mais qui est une route une qui
est un objectif qui est une perspective
c'est ça le leadership suivi les parties
de mon cours à le scpc d'affaires de
management c'est une affaire qui
concerne autant
l'entrepreneur de l'entreprise publique
et le projet politique c'est être
capable de donner la perspective est
capable d'entraîner ses salles
leadership et pour entraîner il faut une
équipe qui sait où elle va et cette
équipe là ça doit être l'équipe
franco-allemande et peut-être que
l'italie puisque je vois que monsieur
draghi fait en ce moment un bon travail
peut-être que l'italie peut participer à
ces dynamiques il ne s'agit pas
d'exclure les autres mais il s'agit
d'avoir un pilotage de l'europe on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui une bataille
mondiale pour le pilotage du monde ça ça
tenait à faire entre la chine les etats
unis si on n'a pas un pilotage de
l'europe on sera écrasé un mot sur pour
finir sur cette question des européennes
et ce débat sur la primauté du droit a
primauté du droit national sur le droit
européen sans débat qui est née avec la
décision de la cour fonctionnelle de la
pologne et il a trouvé écho notamment
dans votre famille politique
michel barnier défend la nécessité d'une
souveraineté juridique en matière
d'immigration xavier bertrand dit que la
souveraineté populaire doit primer
lorsque les intérêts de la france sont
en jeu valérie pécresse à la comtesse la
primauté du droit européen sur les
identités constitutionnel qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ces prises de position
est ce que le souverainisme est en train
de gagner votre vie politique je pense
que
beaucoup de gens parmi les plus
européens les plus tempérée et du centre
de la droite européenne
ont été contraints depuis quelques mois
quelques années mais maintenant de
quitter cette famille politique donc à
une radicalisation à droite la famille
des républicains est donc comme ils ont
mis une procédure que moi je n'approuve
pas qui est cette procédure de désigner
un candidat un par ce type de scrutin au
congrès c'est la course à celui qui sera
le plus près de la base des militants or
ce qu'il faut c'est rassembler les
français et par rassembler les militants
et donc je pense que ils peuvent en
effet rassembler les militants sur des
positions qui sont assez froide en terme
européens mais je pense que la question
aujourd'hui c'est de rassembler la
france et de conduire la france et
conduire la france en ayant pour comme
mission première un engagement auprès
des militants qui sont les plus radicaux
je trouve que ce n'est pas une bonne
logique politique ce n'est pas vraiment
ce gaullisme qui faisait du printemps la
république l'homme qui avait un contact
avec le peuple et qui conduisait le
peuple avec son leadership mais en même
temps avec une forme d'indépendance
vis-à-vis des partis politiques là je
trouve aujourd'hui on est revenu à un
régime de parti et le régime de parti on
le voit bien il n'est pas tout à fait
dans l'intérêt de la france ça veut dire
que la droite quoi sa perte pour vous je
pense que l est pas bien parti pour le
moment et donc mais le président de la
république on va voir pour les
prochaines élections on va parler que
vous c'est de mon point de vue de la
situation est inversée
chez monsieur macron lien leader et
l'organisation politique est fragile et
à droite il ya une implantation
politique qui est très importante les
l'air ils ont gagné les élections
territoriales donc il ya intérêt une
force territoriale puissante mais il ya
des questions pour le leadership donc on
est en situation a bercé presse que la
droite puisque celle-ci de votre livre
choisir un chef est ce qu'aujourd'hui la
droite est encore à même de se choisir
un chef ou est-ce que parmi les cinq
candidats puisque on connaît maintenant
les cinq candidats pour vous aucun est
en mesure d'être un chef je pense qu'il
est la droite peut se donner un chef
peut-elle donner à la france à chef ça
c'est autre chose elle va se donner
achète mais après il faut il pouvoir
rassembler pour la france est à vous en
doutez et moi j'en doute pendant si on
était dans la situation d'aujourd'hui il
faut toujours être prudent parce que les
octobre n'est pas mai mais le la
question pour moi c'est que aujourd'hui
je pense que le leadership
macron efforts et qu'aujourd'hui il n'ya
pas sur la scène politique tel qu'un
leadership comparable au sien en
revanche il ya un leadership
territoriale de la droite française donc
je pense que nous sommes dans une
perspective de cohabitation qu'il faut
étudier je ne sais pas si ça va se
passer mais je crois que la probabilité
que macron gagne mais qu'il n'est pas
l'effet d'entraînement qu'on a pour la
première élection mais que pour
l'instant seconde élection que ce soit
le général de gaulle en 67 de ce soit
mitterrand 88 il n'y a pas eu de vague à
la deuxième législatives et donc pour
moi la probabilité d'une cohabitation
est aujourd'hui assez forte parce qu
avec la droite si on vous suit bien
belle macro remporterait la
présidentielle et la droite
remporteraient les sécheresses je pense
que c'est quelque chose comme ça qui
peut se passer d'où l'importance que va
prendre sur la scène politique edouard
philippe parce qu'il peut peut-être aidé
emmanuel macron a gagné les élections
législatives que son parti a du mal à
gagner la majorité présidentielle je ne
conteste pas ces initiatives mais je la
trouve un peu vain pour eux je la trouve
pas vraiment organisée et puissante
comme il faut qu'une majorité
présidentielle le soir elle vise à
soutenir la réélection d'un président
elle ne tient que sur le leadership de
macron absolument un goût sûr il doit
philippe après je passe la parole à
bêtises parce qu'il a des questions et
sur batterie mais edouard philippe vous
auriez pu le rejoindre edouard philippe
son mouvement horizon c'est une bonne
idée pour vous oui je pense que c'est
une chose c'est une bonne idée il ça
correspond à l'analyse que j'ai c'est à
dire que et l'intérêt de d'edouard
philippe aujourd'hui pour continuer une
ligne politique qu'il a commencé à agir
à matignon c'est de faire en sorte que
macron soit élu que je crois qu'il est
nécessaire à la victoire aux
législatives mais ça va contribuer à la
fin des républicains le mouvement
qu'elle tombera forcément l'abordant
forcément là moi je suis toujours
d'esprit républicain mais je suis là
républicain génération ump c'est à dire
un rassemblement je ne suis pas à gauche
je ne serai pas à gauche je reste
quelqu'un de droite mais
fondamentalement je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il y as possibilité d'avoir une bonne
politique pour la france avec emmanuel
macron pour peu que la politique au
parlement soit une politique qui
respecte le centre droit baptiste alors
oui votre livre en effet c'est une
réflexion sur le leadership mais à
travers cette réflexion vous vous livrer
une analyse de la présidentielle 2022
dans le dernier chapitre il ya une
passage qui a retenu mon attention en
particulier c'est la note que vous
adressez emmanuel macron trait sur 20 à
son leadership électorale sur la base de
cinq critères que vous avez définies
selon vous l'un des autres candidats
aujourd'hui déclaré at il les qualités
en matière de leadership électorale pour
battre le mettrons
personnellement et pour le moment je ne
le crois pas c'est pour ça que je dis
que il faut faire 13 sur 20 dans mon
calcul pour battre macron et je ne vois
pas quelqu'un que j'ai fait les j'ai
fait les notations pour les autres et je
ne vois pas quelqu'un aujourd'hui qui
peut faire très souvent mais mais mais
je post scriptum faisons très attention
parce que l'élection présidentielle ça
peut aussi n'ont pas être un choix
positif ça peut être un refus par roger
est du président et on a vu ça déjà dans
le passé c'est à dire un front anti
président anti sortant donc ce front
anti sortant conduirait des gens qui ont
des positions différentes à droite et à
gauche a voté contre le président de ce
point de vue là par exemple quelqu'un
comme xavier bertrand est un réceptacle
assez large pour avoir des gens de
gauche et des gens de droite qui
pourraient voter pour lui donc je ne dis
pas que macron est assurément réélu
parce qu'un front anti macro est
possible si la droite choisit un moment
ou un autre un candidat qui a un espace
suffisamment large pour récolter les
mécontents se serait pas de vent fou
bombe de mon point de vue pour le pays
forcément quelque chose de très positif
parce que ça veut dire que c'est un vote
de rejet est pas un vote d'adhésion et
qu'après c'est très difficile de
gouverner quand on a été lu par roger je
trouve que monsieur hollande a montré
que c'était assez difficile de créer un
projet parce qu'en fait il avait été élu
surtout sur par antisarkozysme et donc
on a vu qu'il n'avait pas été capable de
tracer une perspective ce rejet anti
mâcon pour vous c'est xavier bertrand
qui en profiterait c'est marine le pen
voir eric zemmour je pense que c'est
xavier bertrand qui en profiteraient si
tel était le cas je pense que c'est
possible mais par définition je vois
quand même que emmanuel macron à ilan
atout formidable c'est que son
expression politique c'est 50% de
jeunesse 50% d'expérience c'est très
rare que le candidat qui va être le plus
jeune soit aussi le plus expérimenté et
donc pour une fois dans le pays on va
avoir un jeune homme qui a la foi a été
président et donc il connaît le job et
en même temps il a l'espérance de la
jeunesse
emmanuel macron vous entendant pas ce
que vous dites vous trompez rarement sur
le résultat d'une élection oui jusqu'à
maintenant juste en plus une fois mais
là je pense que je ne dis pas qu'il va
gagner je dis simplement que il a un
leadership parce que franchement j'ai
gouverner ce pays avec d'autres mais ce
café macron dans cette période là il a
quand même eu toutes les difficultés
faut quand même lui reconnaître ça je
vois temps en temps on fait comme si la
pandémie n'avait pas existé mais cette
pandémie elle est terrible parce que
d'abord elle est en permanence
incertaine on sait pas quels sont les
trois prochains mois vous vernet quand
on connait pas le contexte et trois
prochains mois c'est quelque chose de
très difficile et il le fait plutôt
brillamment
jean-pierre enfin parce que la dynamique
est pour le moment de son côté alors
certes on est à cinq mois de l'élection
vous expliquer comment cette dynamique
est ce que c'est le fait qu'ils abordent
des sujets qui avaient été mis sous le
tapis et que finalement il est comble un
vide laissé peut-être en partie par la
droite je pense que d'abord le fait que
la droite se succèdent à choisir son
candidat a fait qu elle déserte un peu
le débat politique qu'elle ne s'occupe
pas aujourd'hui de de zemmour donc là je
pense qu'il ya un problème en effet delà
de la droite avec son son calendrier
électoral elle aurait dû désigner son
candidat plus tôt mais je pense aussi
que c'est en effet est quelque chose qui
est arrivée depuis les régionales je
pense ou madame le pen finalement à
montrer un peu le vide son projet je
crois que zemmour a révélé le manque de
culture d'enracinement dans l'histoire
de france de madame le pen et que
finalement cette droite cultiver cette
droite qui était la vieille droite
traditionnelle des tic si vignancour
même du père le pen et finalement les
mots il a révélé un peu le creux de le
pen donc il sait et s'installe sur cette
vieille droite qui est traditionnel dans
dans notre pays mais je crois que il n'a
pas forcément
les nerfs il faudra avoir pour une
campagne pleine campagne française c'est
très très difficile et là j'en reviens
dans l'analyse du bouquin c'est que
c'est un bouquin qui fait aussi pour les
étudiants qui sont dans les écoles de
commerce circulent il faut des qualités
personnes il faut du développement
personnel une campagne présidentielle
c'est très très dur c'est quelque chose
qui demande beaucoup de sagesse beaucoup
de profondeur une résistance protéger la
famille c'est quelque chose où
une extrême brutalité et je ne suis pas
sûr qu'on puisse faire une campagne
présidentielle si on n'est pas préparé
sur le plan personnel aussi donc je ne
sais pas si reg démo sera prêt et pour
le moment j'en doute et on a bien
compris votre message et on redonne le
titre de votre livre choisir un chef les
secrets du leadership à travers
l'histoire c'est aux éditions michel
lafon merci beaucoup merci jean pierre
raffarin merci à vous mais venir
[Musique]